Apple just gave its iPhone 14 models a
new satellite connection ah okay we're
connected if you need help it can be
used to send a message to Emergency
Services when you don't have cellular or
Wi-Fi connectivity to test this I'm not
exactly off-grid I'm in Prospect Park in
Brooklyn and apple gave me this test
phone where the cellular radio is
disabled so the satellite connectivity
kicks in the only thing I needed next
an emergency
well that creates a pretty staged demo
where little can go wrong I still got a
really good sense of how this feature
works and how extremely limited the
feature is compared to other satellite
devices okay yes let's say fake Joanna
Falls ready
bye
so I call 9-1-1 but there's no cell
service
so instead the iPhone shows this an
emergency text via satellite button when
I select that I get this screen where I
can select from these options there are
some additional things to answer too who
needs help
me
always
chest pain traumatic injury sickness
stroke drowning other
traumatic injury I can also decide if I
want to alert my emergency contact
now comes the connection to the
satellites which in the demos took
anywhere from a few seconds to a minute
looking for signal
okay I'm going to turn to the right
prompts you to move in different
directions to be better in line with the
satellite which if I really did fall
would be a bit of an issue to the right
to the right like Beyonce says
as soon as it connects a message with
the information you just filled out
begins to be sent via satellite but
here's the interesting thing those
messages may not go directly to
Emergency Services yet if your local
responders don't accept text messages
the message goes to an Apple relay
Center where a person will then relay
the information to local responders to
get you the help you need
in either case a dispatcher may ask for
some additional questions via text
describe the location of the emergency
near a bridge
and a path
and a tree
it takes much longer for the messages to
go through than when on a Cellular
Connection so Apple suggests keeping the
messages shorter so there's less data to
send
okay the local responders have been
notified of my fall in the case of this
demo Apple has cut off those messages
from actual emergency workers like any
piece of satellite equipment the phone
has to be outside with a clear view of
the sky so it can connect to a satellite
apparently this extra
I don't know two feet doesn't help at
all in one test I did run into a
connection issue
uh-oh turn right to find the satellite
I'm not connected anymore it's also more
limited than a dedicated satellite
device like the 400 Garmin inreach Mini
2 and the 250 spot X those devices let
you contact emergency services but also
message friends or family
I miss typing on these so much with the
iPhone feature your emergency contact
will be able to see your conversation
with the emergency dispatcher but they
can't respond the Garmin and spot X
however do require monthly subscriptions
Apple says this feature is free for the
first two years
my guess is that Apple's keeping this
feature free for now because well who
would pay for it maybe I would if I was
frequently in places without reliable
cellular service but even then I may opt
for one of these devices that actually
lets me text family or friends I
wouldn't be surprised to see apple build
its satellite features up over time and
perhaps make some available for a fee
for now like the car crash detection
feature this is a cool Peace of Mind
perk for iPhone 14 owners
I just wouldn't fall for it smile
you really took a fall for the team